merci et merci de votre invitation je
vais m'efforcer comme nous y inciter
tout à l'heure guillaume larrivé de
sortir des postures lorsque convient de
le dire michèle tribalat d'ailleurs il
ya très souvent sur ce sujet des
postures la posture des vrais mou et des
vrais durs ou des fous et des fous dur
donc faut s'efforcer de sortir de cela
pour cela j'ai regardé très
attentivement les enquêtes d'opinion
pour voir comment les français
réagissent aujourd'hui à la question de
la crise migratoire et ont réagi hier
parce que tout cela et vous allez voir
est complexe à la fois dans le temps et
dans l'espace plus complexe que la
brutalité des chiffres ne le donne à
voir souvent alors d'abord qu'en est il
aujourd'hui sur cette question
migratoire on a deux trois enquêtes pour
l'instant essentiellement des enquêtes
de l'institut aux docks ça si ça vous
intéresse dit allez voir sur le site de
ceux de cet institut qui ont posé de
multiples questions sur la question
migratoire
il faut faire attention il pose très
souvent des questions en introduisant
des personnalités politiques et quand
les français répondent ils répondent à
la fois au sujet mais aussi à celui qui
a tenu tel ou tel propos
ça n'est pas ici beaucoup d'hommes
politiques et fins politiques que j'ai
devant moi que je vais apprendre ça on
peut dire une chose quand on l'imputent
à untel ou untel le jugement porte
autant sur la personne que sur les
propos tenus
voilà ensuite dans un deuxième temps je
remettrai dans le temps relativement
long
les perceptions d'aujourd'hui et les
perceptions d'hier sur l'immigration est
ce qui a changé parce que vous allez
voir que c'est un enjeu sur lequel ça
bouge et ça bougera d'ailleurs dans le
temps court
on l'a vu ça a bougé la photo du petit
taylan fait bouger les français et puis
je terminerai en réfléchissant sur les
tensions et les éventuels paradoxe qui
travaille et traverse l'opinion publique
et en particulier nos opinions publiques
qui vous intéresse peut-être plus que
d'autres l'opinion publique des
sympathisants des républicains alors
l'opinion aujourd'hui est une opinion
l'opinion française est marquée par une
perception inquiète et tendu de la
question migratoire beaucoup plus que
dans d'autres pays européens
j'ai regardé des données autrichienne
des données allemandes
j'allais dire l'opinion allemande
l'opinion autrichienne est beaucoup
moins tendue que l'opinion française sur
cette question il y a de la gauche à la
droite une tension dans l'opinion
française qui est forte
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est du 80 20
voiliers 80% d'un côté telle ou telle
option et 20 de l'autre l'opinion reste
partagé quelques exemples simplement on
a interrogé les français sur les propos
du premier ministre manuel valls qui a
déclaré que les migrants qui fuient la
guerre les persécutions la torture les
oppressions doivent être accueillis en
france et vous d'accord ou pas avec les
propos tenus par le premier ministre 46
% des français déclarent leur accord 52%
leur désaccord mais attention via une
imputation à manuel valls on juge autant
manuel valls que les propos qu'il tient
et vous voyez que voilà il y a une
majorité mais une majorité qui n'est pas
écrasante qui désapprouvent les propos
du premier ministre alors quand on
regarde en détail un vrai clivage gauche
droite sur cette affaire les
sympathisants de droite sont seulement à
30% d'accor a pas demandé aux
sympathisants de droite d'être d'accord
avec les propos du premier ministre
socialiste
et les sympathisants de gauche 73 pour
ce deuxième regard la question qui est
une question centrale
la question de l'attitude par rapport à
la politique adoptée par l'allemagne
l'allemagne a assoupli les conditions
d'octroi du statut de réfugiés aux
migrants notamment syriens fuyant la
guerre civile dans leur pays
vous personnellement seriez vous
favorable ou opposé à ce que la france
fasse comme l'allemagne
55% des français sondés favorables 44 %
favorables et on retrouve un clivage
gauche droite à peu près de la même
ampleur que tout à l'heure mais voyez
que c'est pas du 80 20
et puis là on juge autant l'allemagne
que la politique mise en oeuvre par
l'allemagne
les traces dans tidji rhmani sme dans la
population française dans le peuple de
gauche comme dans le peuple de droite ne
sont pas négligeables
loin d'être négligeable donc qu'est-ce
qu'on juge exactement dernier élément
sur la perception de la crise actuelle
l'attitude par rapport à la politique
des quotas
alors là on a put pas à tel ou tel
etes-vous favorables ou opposés à
l'instauration de quotas afin de
répartir les migrants et les demandeurs
d'asile entre les différents pays de
l'union européenne favorable 69%
défavorable 30% et la gauche et droite
sont en majorité favorables à une
politique de quotas donc on voit bien
que c'est fait à faire est plus complexe
qu'elle au premier abord
l'affairé est complexe parce que la
politique de quotas que je sache
l'allemagne ne sont pas complètement
défavorable
cette politique de quotas donc voilà ce
qu'il en est pour la perception sur la
crise actuelle deuxième réflexion le
temps long des perceptions de
l'immigration ça bouge et ça beaucoup
bougé vous allez le voir
cette crispation tension de l'opinion
publique aujourd'hui française est à
replacer dans la crispation qui est
sensible depuis 2009
avant 2009 la perception de
l'immigration s'était beaucoup améliorée
en france beaucoup les tensions avait
beaucoup chuté dans les années
quatre-vingt douze jusqu'au début des
années 2000 et certains événements plus
ou moins lourds
la crise des banlieues de 2005 la crise
économique et financière de 2008-2009 et
un petit effet attentats mais qui n'est
pas majeur ont réintroduit des tensions
très fortes sur la perception de
l'immigration à partir d'une question
qui est très brutal il y a trop
d'immigrés en france vous êtes d'accord
ou non avec cet item
en 2009 c'était moins d'un français sur
deux 49%
aujourd'hui ses 69 ans + 20 points entre
2009 et 2015
donc on voit bien s'il voulait que
quelque chose a changé qu'une tension
forte s'installe de très haut niveau
sont atteints quand vous regardez sans
détails comme c'est une enquête que j'ai
fait faire et j'ai demandé ce que
l'échantillon soit important on peut
dire des choses un peu voilà à partir du
moment où on a deux gros échantillons on
atteint de très haut niveau dans le
grand quart nord-est où là c'est 73% des
français qui habitent ce grand quart
nord-est qui considèrent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés
on atteint de haut niveau dans les
communes rurales qui ne sont pas
forcément je regardait attentivement les
chiffres de michèle tribalat celles qui
sont soumises le plus influent au flux
migratoires
donc vous voyez parfois que les
représentations sont peuvent être
déconnectés un d'une réalité ce qui est
ce qui est normal et légitime
ça atteint de très haut niveau chez les
ouvriers 75 % chez les sans diplômes 72%
chez ce qui est très intéressant comme
j'ai un gros échantillons j'ai les
contrats aidés les contrats d'intérim et
les stagiaires 84%
84 % de cette population qui est une
population fragilisée tout simplement
j'ai les sympathisants de l'ump 86 %
chez les sympathisants du front national
94% donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a eu
dans ça bouge et ça peut bouger à
l'avenir il y a eu un effet crise il y
avait un effet banlieue et il y a un
effet attentat qui a changé un certain
calme qui s'introduisait sur cet enjeu
de l'immigration cependant une fois
qu'on a dit cela fout se méfier de ce
que très souvent les journalistes
peuvent dire de manière hâtive
vous voyez bien une union des droites et
des droites extrêmes est en train de se
mettre en oeuvre autour de l'immigration
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué j'étais
très sensible à ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure sur le mélange à la fois de
fermeté et d'humanité caractéristiques
de votre famille par rapport à celles du
front national
et c'est pas simplement au niveau des
politiques c'est au niveau des
perceptions des électeurs vous allez
voir et des sympathisants en effet les
réactions de l'opinion publique et
particulièrement des sympathisants
républicains ne peuvent être confondus
avec ceux du front national
je donnerai quelques exemples dans l'
enquête fractures françaises qu'on a
fait juste avant l'été et qui a été
publié le monde a publié pas mal
d'extrait de cette enquête et on voit
très bien que vous avez au fond un
électorat qui vit cette tension entre la
fermeté et d'humanité et qui cherchent
parfois de manière plus ou moins à
droite ou maladroites à les faire vivre
ensemble alors que du côté du front
national c'est assez différent
la fermeté l'emportent et parfois
l'humanité est assez difficile à
percevoir
même s'il doit y être comme dans tous
les électorats
les immigrés s'installe en france qui
s'installe en france prennent le travail
des français 29% des français pensent la
fin de 33% des sympathisants de l'ump
sont dans la moyenne nationale
68% des sympathisants du front national
vous voyez que sur cette question
migratoire ça n'est pas la même chose
faut arrêter à force de répéter des
idées fausses advient des faits vrai
quoi il faut faire très attention cette
affaire dans un dans un moment qui est
un moment assez grave sur la question
qui bien sûr est lié que la question de
l'islam parce que si ces immigrés venait
comme ils venaient jadis avant tout de
l'union européenne on n'aurait pas les
tensions on aurait des tensions n'aurait
pas les tensions que l'on a aujourd'hui
l'islam est une religion aussi pacifiste
que les autres et le djihadisme est une
perversion de cette religion
59% des français partagent après les
attentats 59% des français partagent
j'ai dit m 54% des sympathisants de
l'ump
21% des sympathisants du front national
donc oui on pourrait exiger pas vous
abreuver de chiffres c'est vous
intéresse je pourrais vous les données
puis on pourra en parler pour montrer
que voilà dans ces tensions il ne faut
pas faire des paquets cadeaux ou mais
voilà des électorats qui sont porteurs
de systèmes d'attitude différents
ensembles c'est un peu plus compliqué
que cela comme toujours quand on se
donne la peine d'aller voir la réalité
de près et d'ailleurs il suffit ensuite
de regarder simplement la perception
qu'il y à des sympathisants de l'ump par
rapport au front national le parti le
front national est un parti xénophobe
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou non
avec cet item 61% des français 58% des
sympathisants de l'ump
bien sûr front national extrêmement
faible on les comprend d'ailleurs voilà
mais vous voyez les choses sont sont
sont plus complexes et je voudrais
conclure par les
chance à venir là on a vu le présent le
passé l'avenir on voit comment les
régionales démarre on a l'impression que
l'immigration va être le sujet essentiel
alors que personnellement sauf si vous
m'informez le poids des collectivités
régionales même renforcé par la loi
notre sur l'enjeu migratoire me semble
assez faible
donc une fois de plus on va parler aux
français de deux sujets qui sont pas
voilà qui n'ont strictement rien à voir
je dis attention attention à force de
parler aux français de sujets qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les élections
auxquelles on les convoque on peut avoir
de très mauvaises surprises un très
mauvaise surprise et celle de
renforcement de la classe politique une
fois de plus il nous parle de sujets qui
n'ont rien à voir avec attention je dis
ça parce que nous rentrons en campagne
des régionales et qu'il faut être
prudent
d'autre part cercle la situation change
mais souvenons nous de la présidentielle
de 2012 j'étais revoir mes classiques
ressortir les grandes enquêtes que l'on
faisait à l'époque sur pourquoi les
français s'étaient rendus aux urnes pour
voter sarkozy hollande bayrou mélenchon
et autres et on leur offrait à l'époque
une quinzaine de motivation vous voyez
sujets économiques sujets sociaux et
bien sûr les migrations
il y avait treize motivation la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine était
en dixième position
la question de l'intégration des
minorités dans la société française
était en 13e position alors ça va monter
pour la prochaine présidentielle
mais attention les français ont aussi
envie qu'on leur parle d'autre chose
parce que là en ce moment quand on
écoute les radios léonie côté télévision
écouter on se dit mais ces voix là c'est
devenu la grande question
oui c'est une grande question puisqu'on
y consacre ici une matinée bien sûr que
c'est une question importante mais il
faudra peut-être un perspectives
extrêmement sérieuse de 2017 savoir
parler de manière crédible aussi
d'autres d'autres choses et à cet égard
je regardais en 2012 les motivations
délectera de l'ump leur structure de
motivation pour se déplacer aux urnes et
dieu saisissant
être un problème plus important qu'en
2012 par convaincre les français d'y
aller cette fois c'est un jeu les
électeurs ump j'étais assez proche de la
moyenne nationale
les électeurs fn dès 2012 il était très
sûr ces questions d'immigration etc
mais les électeurs de l'ump lors brin
leur principale préoccupation
j'ai ça sous les yeux en 2012
l'électorat de sarkozy c'était la lutte
contre le chômage la réduction de la
dette et des déficits
l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat lé
financement du système de protection
sociale et la lutte contre l'insécurité
voilà est loin derrière l'intégration
des minorités et la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
voilà mais voyez pas c'est pas pour
minorer ses affaires mais c'est pour
relativiser essayé d'envisager cette
question avec l'équilibré la dignité
qu'ils méritent
voilà merci